alright I propose we get started plan
for today is to finish up an Li I was
just talking with the group that was
here before and I think the canoe
is that if we finish that early I'm
going to give you a glimpse of the
topics for next week because they're
basically my favorite topics and I want
to like get people to do projects on
them and I know that we're introducing
that content kind of late in terms of
people settling on project topics but
maybe this is my last chance to sneak
some things in I've got lots of good
links to datasets and papers and so
forth that would be about that get us
pretty close to the true dream of NLU I
think which is like you know language
use and grounded situations in the real
world and it just comes late in the
course because we have to build up a lot
of material to get to the relevant
models but now certainly by the end of
the day today you're well-prepared to
get your hands dirty with the kinds of
things that fall under ground and
language understanding so I might say a
few things about that if there's time
and just by the way it's going to get a
little bit of rush next week we have
just one day for grounded language
understanding and one day for semantic
parsing the saving grace there is that
we have a huge amount of material for
semantic parsing it's a challenging
topic it's a very interdisciplinary you
basically have to know a bunch of
linguistic semantics and a bunch of
machine learning but if that sounds
exciting to you then it's a wonderful
area to work in and we have this whole
code base sippy-cup and bill has created
lots of notebooks for it and then we
have to supporting screencasts that kind
of get to the essence of the technical
ideas and then a bunch of wonderful
papers so if you're still looking around
for a project idea and especially if you
took semantics with me before then this
is like the the dream the marriage of
linguist 130 a and this course and so I
encourage you to check it out and Bill
will give us an introduction to it but
there's not only so much you can do in
an hour
so it will really pay to do that kind of
self-study just while I'm talking about
the schedule so you're out you're doing
the last homework and the last bake-off
and then after that we kind of settle
into a rhythm of project oriented
assignments you do a lit review and at
that point you'll be paired with a
mentor from the project team who will be
with you through the whole process so
like somebody you can count on for
advice and we'll be giving you a lot of
feedback so we do the lit review first
and then we have this thing called
experimental protocol and I'll tell you
much more about what that's supposed to
contain closer to the time but kind of
hovering in the background here is that
we're going to push you to make sure
that your project has some kind of
quantitative evaluation associated with
it not because we think that that has to
be the way all work in NLU works but
rather just because we think it's
healthy to kind of push you in that
direction and that's why you'll find
that when you when you interact with
people from the teaching team about your
project they want to know what data
you're going to use because I think that
we all on the teaching team think if we
can figure out what data you're going to
use then we can kind of figure out what
your metrics will be and get you to the
point of a quantitative evaluation so
have that in mind as well as you do
project planning and know that the
project assignments are going to be
pushing you in that direction and then
after that it's just a short YouTube
video those are typically fun and then
the final paper itself and
correspondingly most of the material
that we do in class in the second half
of the course is kind of oriented toward
you doing your projects it's kind of it
gets a little bit meta we talk about
methods and metrics and presenting your
work and so forth so it should be
relevant to you no matter what kind of
project you're working on that's the
rationale there's one thing that I
wanted to just clarify about bake-off
four just so that you know what the
points of freedom are so remember
homework four and bake-off four are all
about word level entailment it's a kind
of small version of the nli problem and
I've supplied you with datasets that you
can work with and anything goes for this
in terms of you bringing in outside
vectors for example you could do it with
Elmo or Bert or vectors you build
yourself glove write you name it you can
go onto the web and in fact the the task
is pushing you in the direction of
having really rich inputs to these
models otherwise you're just not going
to do very well
so from the perspective of modeling and
outside data that will initialize your
your vectors we want to be you know cast
the net wide there is one restriction
that I feel like I didn't emphasize
enough last time though which is that
when you get down to it when you develop
your original system and when you enter
the bake-off you have to be working Oh
with the word disjoint problem right it
says that here keep in mind that for the
bake-off evaluation the edge disjoint
portions of the data are off-limits you
can train on any combination of word
disjoint train and dev you just can't
look at that edge disjoint part and the
reason for that is that this problem
your performance just goes way up if
you're allowed to look at edge disjoint
and the reason for that is that that
means that in training you get a lot of
words that you see at test time which is
kind of contrary to the direction and
I'm trying to push us which is these are
all new words at test time and so what
we're doing is kind of stress testing
your system on its ability to generalize
from what it knows about its training
words into a new part of the vocabulary
so yeah this is really important and you
will definitely not be allowed to win
the bake-off if we see that you've
brought in the edge destroying stuff you
know I'm actually so I'm assuming that
whatever embedding space you have when
it gets to test time those words are in
that embedding space because that's kind
of the point because it's like you're
embedding space has interesting
structure and then your model helps you
generalize into the entailment problem
so your system is going to do really
poorly in fact if none of the test words
are in your embedding I've tried to
disguise where I got the entailment data
and the spirit of that is just that you
know you guys can search widely and
stuff as long as you don't make a
deliberate effort to figure out where my
data come from that would be contrary to
the spirit of all of this but definitely
go out and see you know whether there
are new word embeddings that people have
released that are especially good for
this task ok any questions about that
before we dive back into the content
okay just as a kind of recap so last
time I introduced the problem of nli and
I think the summary of that discussion
is kind of like nli at this point is a
common-sense reasoning task of some kind
you know
kind of hard to define exactly what the
criteria are for entailment and
contradiction in neutral but we have
these naturalistic data sets that
reflect some aspects of how humans
actually reason about language and
that's what we hope our systems do as
well because the whole idea of analyze
that it's kind of keyed into fundamental
information about how we use language to
build arguments and to reason and to
find out new information and if you
think in an extended sense even how to
answer a question and so forth I
introduced SN Li in multi and Li which
are exciting large data sets that can
that will test disparate different
aspects of your systems so SN Li is just
image captions and multi nli is drawn
from a bunch of different genres and a
nice twist about multi n li is that in
addition to the diversity of the
training data there are two dev sets one
which is matched which means that you
evaluate on the same genres that you
trained on and one mismatched which is
kind of seeing it gives you a chance to
see how well your system can generalize
out of its comfort zone so to speak and
another exciting thing about multi n Li
is that the team released it with a
bunch of annotations that you can use
for kind of error analysis and I'm going
to give you a bunch of illustrations of
that later I think it's a nice
opportunity you know writing a good
error analysis section for your paper is
often very difficult and requires a lot
of creativity and I feel like they've
given you this gift of the structure for
a very rich error analysis by providing
these annotations so I'll show you a bit
about how that works and then we got as
far as talking about hand-built features
which are kind of like word overlap word
cross product and what you're seeing
here is a bunch of stuff that you can
derive from wordnet the one and then
here a bunch of other ideas I added one
slide here which is we have this
narrative of like talking about
hand-built features and linear models
and then talking about deep learning
models and you could fall into a trap of
thinking that these ideas are in direct
competition I think that's not so I
think it could be very interesting and
maybe some of you have done this in your
work so far to think about combining
like a word embedding or something short
and dense we
a feature representation that comes from
hand-built features and that will have
the characteristic that it will have
very high dimensionality and be very
sparse and that really contrasts with
what you would get from Bert or Elmo or
Glove or whatever which tend to be very
short low dimensional and very dense
I've kind of represented that here short
and dense long and sparse and the
question arises then like what's an
effective way to combine these two
representations in a unified model right
because it's not like I have to choose
just long and sparse or short and dense
maybe I can have the advantage of both
and the naive thing to do would be to
just concatenate these two
representations so that if like the
Green has 20,000 dimensions which is
pretty realistic and the short and dense
one has 50 then you have 20,000 and 50
dimensions but even that way of posing
it suggests that there might be an issue
here right which is that there's a kind
of wild imbalance and it's two kinds of
imbalance on the one hand you have all
this sparsity dominating the
representation on the other hand it's
kind of in two phases like with very
different kinds of information so I
think it might not be effective to
simply concatenate the two
representations one thing that I have
found effective in various work that
I've done recently is to do a little bit
of pre-processing on the long and sparse
side to just make it short and dense and
there are kind of two classes of
approach you could take there so you
could just apply something that is
outside of the model you're developing
like you know apply LSA or PSA or
something like that to shrink it down
into a dense representation that's one
step that's what I've called this model
external transformation another approach
would be to actually have your model
learn some weights that perform that
transformation that embed this really
long thing into a smaller space that
will reintroduce some difficulties of
optimization but I think if you give it
separate parameters then it will become
kind of manageable and then at that
point you would concatenate short and
dense and short and dense here and you'd
have kind of two comparable objects and
then move forth and I think that there's
good evidence that that representation
would have a lot of the advantages
both sides of the incoming information
yeah combine the two I don't know about
that attention would normally be defined
over entire representations not over the
individual dimensions so you'd have to
think about it somewhat create
creatively does that ring any bells for
you over on the teaching team if you
perform this transformation then this
thing went once concatenated if you have
subsequent weights up here then you're
giving your model a chance to learn lots
of interactions between those two sides
and I think that's where this becomes
potentially so powerful okay and then I
introduced nli experiment which is not
required for the homework but if you
want to do a project online there lie I
think this could give you a real
headstart and it kind of makes all these
ideas concrete and I introduced these
two ways of doing hyper parameter
selection in the context of a really
large data set where you can't afford to
sit around through 50 iterations because
you know that could consume all your
time or resources and then toward the
end here I introduced this idea of a
hypothesis only baseline and the
relevance of that is just that this can
be a surprisingly good baseline for nli
and I gave you a rationale that was a
kind of linguistic scientific rationale
for why this works related to the fact
that there are some intrinsic biases
when it comes to entailment problems
about what's likely to appear on the
left or the right and that wasn't my
kind of justification for why hypothesis
only might always be pretty strong and
you can see here at the bottom that it
is indeed quite a strong baseline 65%
and compared to random 33% you know it
looks like you really want to think
about the strength of the hypothesis
only baseline and then asked what about
premise only experiments and I had not
thought enough about that
and so in the moment I think I said
something like well based on what I said
they ought to be pretty good as well
because the same kind of biases that are
telling you for example that if I give
you a general word it's likely to be a
hypothesis
conversely if I give you a very specific
word it's likely to be a premise in an
entailment pair and also very specific
things are likely to be participating in
contradictions in the sense of this
problem because they're likely to
exclude other event descriptions and all
of that leads and pushed me in this
direction all that leads to think that a
premise only baseline ought to be pretty
good so I ran this experiment on SNL I
and I was like aghast so 33.3 which is
the very definition of random for this
problem and at first I thought there
must be some kind of bug in the code or
something because there's just no way it
could be this random and that then I and
I couldn't find any bugs and so I
started to do some real soul-searching
like did I give you guys a misleading
assessment of this problem that's all I
was in a kind of bad state for a while I
guess and then I figured it out does
anybody actually see already what I was
missing in running this on SNL I was
this subtle fact it took me a while to
realize it that's true and I had you to
bring in the local task but I don't
think that's the answer why is it random
for SNL I it's because of the way the
data set was constructed so every
premise was given to crowd workers and
exactly one of entailment contradiction
in neutral was constructed on the basis
of that premise
so those constructed sentences differ
wildly of course and they do contain
biasing information about the label but
if I give you only the premise this was
like what the crowd workers got before
they started their work and so what you
see is exactly what you get from the
data collection which is perfect
randomness because all the system has is
this unbiased information so few and
then I did just to reassure myself check
what that what it is
for the word entailment model because
your homework asks you to do hypothesis
only and that's about 0.5 premise only
is about 0.47 so those are pretty strong
baselines again it's the same lesson but
here I think my insights are at least
consistent with those results so all is
well with the world I guess that's the
bottom line here as far as I know
questions about that our additional
concerns because kind of by construction
any of the premises could have led to
any kind of result like you could have
constructed something that was entailed
or a contradiction or neutral in fact
even more by design that's like
literally the crowd worker was given the
premise and constructed three sentences
one entailment one contradiction one
neutral so it's not just by chance this
was really by design and I should have
known this I did eventually Oh whew
okay so that's a kind of recap with a
little bit of new information and then
the final things I wanted to do was move
into the neural realm because I think
there's exciting models that are kind of
specific to nli that we can discuss yeah
just just a quick question previously so
what about the logistic regression model
with differentiated from this model and
let it have a higher baseline oh well I
just purchased a regression for the
experiment down here just to have some
model to implement premise and
hypothesis only baselines and the
observation is just that both of them
have a lot of information that makes
them much better than random to have no
bias when it comes to the premise but
the word entailment one was not it's
just a bunch of words drawn from some
vocabulary okay
so there are kind of two classes of
models here that and that this is a
byproduct of us having a premise and a
hypothesis the first class are what I'm
going to intense encoding models and in
these models you get a separate summary
representation of the premise and the
hypothesis and then you do something
with it I think this is the kind of
model that your push toward if you have
in mind the IDO dogon dream that you're
learning representations from nli data
that are gonna transfer to lots of other
tasks because for many other tasks you
need an individual sentence
representation and this offers exactly
that and I've started here with a
natural baseline for this kind of model
which is just that kind of sum of word
vectors approach that you've explored in
various places before so just to
summarize this I've got every dog danced
as my premise every poodle moved as the
hypothesis I do an embedding lookup to
get this layer right that would come
from some pre trained space presumably
and then to get a fixed dimensional
representation for each side here
because the word the number of words
could differ you just do something
that's a kind of hard summary of all
those vectors like the sum or the
average or the difference or whatever
right but some operation that's going to
take you from this collection of vectors
into a single fixed dimensional one and
that would give you X P and X H and then
after that again this is familiar you
might just concatenate them or do
something else with them to get to the
input to your classifier and then from
there this could be any classifier you
want so a simple linear one or a whole
deep learning model whatever you choose
and this is a baseline in the sense that
this is a pretty primitive way to
combine all those words into a fixed
dimensional representation but actually
these models turn out often to be pretty
good a lot of information from the words
ends up encoded in those sums that you
get for the premise and the hypothesis
makes sense and here you can see that
like you know one simple approach you
could take to the bake-off would be you
know I just have a one-word premise and
a one-word hypothesis so there's nothing
to sum or average I get XP and XH to
rectly concatenate them and then fit a
model make sense questions about it
here's some code for doing that and it's
familiar code in the sense that like
glove leaves fie glove leaves 5a some
phi these are functions that you've
actually worked with before and the only
twist here is just that as you process
examples you need to process two parts
the premise and the hypothesis whereas
before when you've done this you were
processing like just a Stanford
sentiment treebank representation but
everything else is the same and it does
okay on SNL I hear training train dev
51.6% so actually below the hypothesis
only baseline which cut might make this
a kind of non-starter but it could still
give you intuitively some information
about like a model that you build on top
of this how much you're adding if you do
something more sophisticated than the
sum or the average the way this model
does here's what I take to be the
rationale I kind of alluded to this
before so first encoding the premise and
hypothesis separately might give the
model a chance to find rich abstract
relationships between them you might
think that that's a kind of very human
way of doing this like I have a an
understanding of the premise an
understanding of the hypothesis and then
there's a subsequent step of figuring
out what their relationship is and
that's more or less directly encoded in
this class of model and in addition this
is the Edo dog and dream sentence-level
encoding could facilitate transfer to
other tasks so yeah so if you wanted to
do like the glue benchmark for example
but it's really natural to choose a
sentence encoding model so that you
could use the premise or hypothesis in
one of the sentiment tasks or in one of
the grammaticality judgment tasks and
stuff
here's a model that's received a lot of
attention in the literature that is a
kind of step up in complexity from that
simple averaging or summing of vectors
and this is where I kind of have to RN
ends so one for the premise and one for
the hypothesis so I've used the same
example every dog danced every poodle
moved I looked them up in what I presume
is a single embedding space although you
could have different embedding spaces
for premise and hypothesis if you wanted
to you know on the assumption that word
senses are different depending on where
they appear and then what I am assuming
here is that you would have different
parameters for this recurrent neural
network so I put that in green and in
purple here just a signal that at that
level you might want to learn something
very different depending on what the
environment for the content is but
that's not forced either you could have
tied parameters it could be a single RNN
I think the point here is that the way
this model subsequently works is that I
get this final representation a ch3 and
this one over here HP and those get
combined somehow maybe concatenation
that's a likely choice and those get fit
into the classifier and so what you're
really depending on is that like the
final state in this RNN is a good
summary representation of that example
and similarly for the hypothesis and
then they get concatenated and you make
a classification decision so from the
top here once you get to combo this is
exactly like that first baseline that I
showed you you should really think of
this as like instead of having something
primitive like sum or average to combine
my word vectors I have this really
complicated function an RNN and it has
parameters that I learn as part of the
task instead of imposing this ideal from
on high that sum is the right choice
where that mean is the right choice for
all you know your network is going to
discover that the sum was exactly the
right function to learn that's unlikely
but conceptually I think it's useful to
think about that possibility and of
course this has many variants so like
even our code base will let you explore
a variant where this is a bi-directional
RNN and in that case you might be using
a summary representation derived like
sort of
eh one point combined with the one from
h3 those might get concatenated and
that's your representation of the
premise and same for the hypothesis but
you would feed all of that into this
combo funkier and fit a classifier make
sense questions it would be wonderful to
see you guys exploring different
variants of these I've only provided one
and here's a kind of strategy for
actually I did implement this full one
in the notebook you can see that linked
up here but I thought for here instead
of just looking at the code which you
can do on your own it would be more
useful to talk about the conceptual
strategy that I took for implementing
this so sentence encoding RNN how would
I implement this model here using PI
torch so here's the way I thought about
it first it's it's nice and clean it
gives you good code if you define a
dataset class the code that's in the
repository by and large for these models
it deals with just a single example so a
single sequence of words a single length
and a single label that's like what you
would do if you just use the RNN class
it would force you into that mode of
having a single list we need to so for
the data set you could subclass the
existing one and just have it yield
batches of objects that are pairs like
every dog danced as tokens every poodle
moved as tokens their individual lengths
and then finally the label so that's
kind of like bookkeeping that's just
imposed on you by the structure of the
model that your examples need to look
like that then for the classifier model
itself the subclass of NN module in pi
torch you need it to conceptually be a
premise RNN and a hypothesis RNN so what
you do is implement its forward method
to use those two on rnns
and they get you know the premise and
hypothesis get processed in exactly the
same way as the current RNN code is
processing regular examples
and it gives you the two final State
representations and then you just need
to by hand as part of the forward method
concatenate them and return them and
those will get fed into the classifier
and then finally the the way the code is
written you don't really need to do
anything to the base class for rnns when
you define this this special one it just
needs a slightly different predict
problem method and the reason it needs a
different predict method is that it
needs to deal with examples like this
right that's a that's kind of just back
to the fact that your data are a certain
way but everything else about the logic
of optimizing the model is the same
really the changes are localized to
dat'll data handling and to the
structure of this core like what you
think of as the computation graph and I
do love PI torch because it makes all
this so easy and with actually if you
look at the notebook you'll see that in
relatively little code you get one of
these sentence encoding models and then
because you're inheriting from a simpler
class all the options like whether it's
bi-directional and what the hidden
activation function is and the
dimensionalities and so forth that's
kind of all just taken care of make
sense now I encourage you to look at the
code and you'll see you know it's like
50 lines or something most of it is just
bookkeeping final entrant into this
class of sentence encoding models would
be again just a small variant of the one
that we just saw instead of having to
rnns
you have to tree our n ends write
recursive you know tree structured
neural networks you know and so that if
you look at just the premise or just the
hypothesis this is exactly the model
that we used or that I showed you for
the SST and all the same variance holds
so if you wanted like more calm more
complex combination functions than the
one that I've signaled here you could
introduce those and it would all be kind
of nicely modularized because you would
just be dealing with a tree or in a tree
or a recursive neural network
you would define it for the premise and
the hypothesis get their final states
concatenate them and fit the classifier
so from this point on it looks like
exactly all those others other models
and again I think this would be pretty
straightforward to implement given the
tree are n n PI torch implementation
that comes with the course repo all
right and that's it for the sentence
encoding models I hope that gives you a
sense for the ways that you could impose
new innovations and so forth
the second class that I wanted to
introduce I've called chained models and
the reason I've called them chained is
that basically you just run together the
premise and hypothesis the simplest
version of that is the one that I've
given here where I have every dog danced
every poodle moved you could insert your
own boundary symbol if you wanted if you
thought it was important for the model
to learn that transition point it could
be like a unique token that you learn a
unique embedding for but in principle
you could just run them together like
this and then have you know the same
embedding space that's all these gray
cells and then the same RNN parameters
process the entire thing premise and
hypothesis together and then finally on
the basis of the final state here make a
classifier prediction and it could be
bi-directional in which case it would be
using H 6 and H 1 as the basis for the
classifier you know all the same
variance apply here I mean this is
literally just using the RNN that you
might have used already where I just
feed in the blurred together premise and
hypothesis and process it right this is
the I guess the rationale for this would
be like the premise really and truly
establishes the context for the
hypothesis because it has it's as though
a human reader has gone through and just
read them and then made a decision about
them blurred together example pair and
maybe that yeah as I say here maybe that
corresponds to some real processing
metaphor or something then this is the
throw away here like you don't have to
really do anything except
to define a new feature function which
just concatenates the leaves of the two
trees and then everything else is just
code that's already in the course repo
and you can run your experiments in the
usual way
and here's a simple variant where I
decide that I'm going to run together
the premise and hypothesis but now I'm
going to give them sled separate
parameters so I have like an RNN for the
premise here and an RNN for the
hypothesis green and purple and the
linking point is just that the initial
hidden state of the hypothesis RNN is
the final state of the premise RNN but
but you know but different parameters
for the two and this is kind of
intermediate between the sentence
encoding thing which was keeping them
completely separate and the blurred
together one that I just showed you
because they do get blurred together but
with different parameters reflecting
different parts of the example yeah and
then obviously this has lots of variance
as well where I could fill around with
different views on each of these rnns
bi-directional different hidden
activation functions different cell
structure and so forth just I'm just
curious based on what I presented do
people have intuitions about which model
is likely to be better I think there is
a kind of clear winner if I've read the
leaderboards correctly in terms of just
raw performance at the nli problem do
people have intuitions about which one
to bet on well it seems to capture the
entire premise and I thought this
promising conclusion and also have a
delineation between both of them I would
imagine that maybe it's more expressive
than having just this concatenation so
maybe I forgot one but I think we've
presented three different options oh so
your bed is this one the first what
about this one yeah this thing would be
weaker because you don't have a
separation weaker than the sentence
encoding ones like
I'm okay I think
I don't know I'm not really sure how
this combination function works though a
concatenation functions it would likely
just be concatenation because but all
those models have that in common right
because the idea is I get these two
representations for premise and
hypothesis and I want both of them to
contribute to the classifier decision so
concatenation is a good choice because
then it will give the weights that I
learn above that for the classifier it
will have access to all the different
dimensions from both premise and
hypothesis so I think that part is
shared combo right like this certainly
has it
I guess this doesn't have it but if it
was bi-directional then you'd probably
concatenate h6 and h1 having run in the
reverse direction so but what was your
ranking it was one you know anybody
anybody else have bets yeah I've been on
this is a tree or a No oh this one here
yeah so if we stuck to our lens this
would be the best one was that our ends
tend to lose some information over time
so unless we're using an upgraded or an
M like an LST I'm rgr you I think that
having two separate ones and then
combining their outputs is likely to
perform better oh that's interesting
yeah just in keeping it shorter here and
getting this representation here and
kind of saving it for the classifier I
might be doing better and I'd say like
that might hold even if you've got a
sophisticated cell like an LST M just
because these things inevitably get kind
of at anyway oh that's an interesting
insight yeah and actually maybe you'll
have to really look at these
leaderboards here because the way you
frame that that insight attention which
I'm going to show you next is highly
relevant to this because to the extent
that I'll have mechanisms that help me
remember distant information the
calculus might change but still I like
that that intuition yeah we're a simple
our man is best because if you don't
have a lot of data then maybe you're not
gonna have enough data to be able to
differentiate the difference
your hypothesis and everything so to
just have a good language model frankly
seems like you'd want to take advantage
of both verses if you had a ton of data
I can see how having two different ones
would give a little bit more richness oh
that's another great insight yeah yeah
just if you think about data versus the
number of parameters that you need to
learn then small data might do best with
this one which is the kind of most
minimal model that I presented yeah
correct me if I'm wrong but I think that
these models are the best performing
models especially if you allow that you
can have attention and that sentence
encoding models are chosen by and large
by people who are doing multitask
learning so they want a representation
of the individual sentences so that it
can transfer to other tasks or
representations from other tasks can
easily transfer into this one but it's
like if you just want to solve an Li you
pick a model that's like this and you
add attention mechanisms which I'll show
you next and that's like a very powerful
approach yeah the best do you mean on
the bake-off data or on the original
data set cuz I guess if the way they
created the hypothesis was by reading
the premise and then saying hmm I'm
gonna now write an entailment that model
might model exactly that process so this
is for a scintilla feature based models
that's like handcrafted stuff those are
up here sentence vector based models
that's like the sentence encoding ones
the top score there is currently 87
point four on the test set and then down
here I think these before we get to be
ensembles I think these are by and large
so that's a tree one but I think a lot
of these are the chained but separate
premise and hypothesis LS TMS and these
numbers tend to be a bit higher right
even setting aside the ensembles
well it's less obvious just at a glance
exactly what these models are doing but
I'm pretty sure I'm right for these big
well used asks chained separate RN ends
are the best performing with attention
so let me show you the attention that's
the final stage here so here are the
guiding ideas for attention mechanisms
we need more connections between the
premise and hypothesis both classes a
model that I showed you are kind of
limited in what they allow so the
sentence encoding ones just use the
final two representations and
concatenate them and all that other
information is kind of it has to be
summarized by the two that I use for the
classification decision otherwise it's
lost here's a more informal statement of
this in processing the hypothesis your
model needs some reminders of what's in
the premise and that final hidden
representation isn't enough to get those
kind of reminders and then another
guiding insight here might be that it's
useful to have a kind of soft alignment
between the premise and hypothesis
alignment is an early insight from
approaches to nli where people would use
algorithms to construct kind of high
fidelity alignments between premise and
hypothesis and use that as the basis for
making decisions about entailment and
you can imagine that attention
mechanisms especially the word by word
ones that I show you a kind of a soft
way to explore that kind of alignment by
establishing some connections and
learning waits on those connections but
again this is all in the spirit of kind
of making more dense interconnections
between the two parts of your examples
I'm going to start with the what I think
is the simplest version of attention
you'll see that it's already kind of
involved but I think I can convey to you
the intuitions about how this works
so again we have our familiar example
every dog dance some poodle danced and
this will be the target stay here HC so
I use HC
a score vector that combines HC with h1
h2 and h3 you can see them here and this
is the simplest variant in the sense
that all I'm doing is forming the dot
product it's kind of like unnormalized
cosine similarity and that gives me a
vector of scores alpha here those scores
get normalized by a softmax function
into what are properly called the
attention weights and so that's another
vector of length 3 in our example here
giving a weight a kind of weight on this
in this case the association or the
similarity between HC and each one of
these elements then you get what's
called a context vector and a simple
version of that would be just that I
take each one of these and multiply it
by its attention weight down here and
then take their average so this is a
vector that has the same dimensionality
as each one of these hidden states it's
just been weighted by attention and the
attention weight is measuring similarity
with this final state which is so
important for these problems then you do
some kind of attention combination
function so here I've concatenated K
this representation with the final
representation here and fed it through a
kind of dense layer and apply to an
activation function and that gives you
what I've called the attention
combination representation
here's another variant where I have
separate parameters for the context
vector and for this vector here and just
sum them very similar I think and then
finally you fit a classifier on top of
this attention combination in the usual
way and make your classification
decision so it looks like a lot but you
know intuitively what's happening is in
this basic form here I'm getting a
measure of similarity with the final
vector that gets averaged into this
context vector and then that context
vector
and the usual thing that we use for
prediction is fed through into this
classifier to make a final decision
right so it's like the usual thing and
then Kay would be what I called the
reminders an attention weighted view of
what happened previously in the premise
that's been like fast-tracked up as an
input to the classifier here's a
specific example just in case you're the
sort of person who likes to see numbers
here so imagine these are all just two
dimensional vectors I get those scores
and here the intuition which you could
probably read off of the vector values
is that the first word every is really
very similar to danced and it's got high
magnitude so you get a really large
unnormalized cosine similarity value and
then they sort of drop off and then they
get normalized by the softmax function
which sort of flattens things out and
then I do the mean to get that context
vector and that context vector is
dimension two right it's just an average
of all these weighted vectors from down
over here and that gets concatenated
with this representation I hope you can
see that in the purple so that gives me
four-dimensional vector which I feed
through this dense layer to get the
attention combination and then finally
that gets fed into the classifier as
before yeah seems to me like the larger
your output vector the more attention
you get pretty much no matter what like
it's the highest weight because it had
larger numbers did yeah on this and
that's because well it's not only larger
numbers but also larger numbers that are
very similar to this final
representation that's sort of the way I
cooked things up so that you would see
what the vectors are but you're right in
the sense that the more similar I am to
this final representation and the larger
my magnitude the greater my attention
weight will be you're gonna get pretty
close to the original vector yeah
I made up the balance so I think you
have exactly the right intuition yeah so
to what extent does what do we do
benefit from the attention versus just
seeing all of the hidden states from
previously like how much does which
where does the attention like it's an
interesting question so how would I see
all the other states so like if you just
had a classifier on all of those in
addition to the final one like would
that give you the same like result sets
using a press attention layer I see what
you mean so how would that model deal
with varying lengths for the premise or
the hypothesis especially the premise in
this case if it could be three four five
six if I didn't know the length how
would I summarize them into something
that was fixed dimensional so that I
could feed it in the way I think that
would be the blocker to actually just
literally reusing them and so the
attention mechanism is giving us a kind
of blurry look back in a way that for
this mechanism is just hard-coded to be
waiting things that are similar to this
final representation higher but we're
going for the same intuition which is
that we want to kind of bring them back
in the idea is that like all these
models they are kind of like as they
move through data they have a kind of
hazy view of their own past and then we
want to give them these reminders in a
sense and the reminders come through
this very thin pipe on this model but
this is a good transition point so there
are other scoring functions that people
have explored I just showed you the dot
product but you could have learned
parameters in here like this one that's
called general by long at all that's
like general because it's giving us this
like way of combining HC the final
representation with each one of these
vectors and learn parameters for that
kind of by linear combination and so
that's giving us a chance to go way
beyond the hard-coded ideal of the dot
product
into learning just in general what what
relationships are valuable for the
problem that I'm trying to solve and
concat is very similar here I think the
crucial innovation from both of these is
that you're learning weights as part of
the attention mechanism it's a wonderful
question I mean yes and if you look at
the literature especially the early
literature on attention which was
focused on machine translation that's in
fact the way they're defined right so I
have attention for this state but I also
have it for this one and this one all
the way through the hypothesis or you
know the translation the reason that's
meaningful is because in translation
each one of these has an output so
you're like predicting a word for
example whereas in nli you have an
output only in this last state so for
this presentation if you did compute
them for all these other steps the
information would just disappear
and that's a limitation of the places
where we're getting supervision so for
this global attention the answer is kind
of no it's not worth doing for every
step in the hypothesis but that's a nice
transition to word by word attention so
we're by word attention is going to try
to make good on exactly your intuition I
would like to get information at all of
these steps about what my premise was
like but it gets more involved so here
let me see how well I can do this so
every dog dance some poodle moved focus
your attention on this B state and keep
in mind that this has a kind of
recursive property so you'll feel a
little bit at sea at the start first
representation to build this is kind of
feeding it's looking at be here so B
gets copied over and it gets waited by
the previous attention waits K which
came from this a representation I didn't
show you those but just imagine you had
them so i reweighed b by those attention
things and then i add in all of the
vectors
from everything in the premise right so
this gets copied these are all the same
but the reason they're repeated is so
that I can add in all the previous
states so this would be for whatever
dimensionality you had for the premise
you can see already that in this case
I'm going to have to make the
simplifying assumption that I have the
same length for the premise and
hypothesis so that this parameters these
parameters W are well defined but I hope
you can see that the fundamental thing
is we're bringing in all of the premise
a kind of infusing the current state
with everything from the premise and
then feeding it through this neural
layer to get em now and doesn't have the
right dimensionality for us going
forward so the true weights for this are
fed through a softmax combination of M
with some other learned weights W which
are performing this transformation then
I get what is kind of like the context
vector that we saw before and here it's
all those premise states again weighted
by alpha B and then you bring in also
the previous attention weights here
that's K a and you get some parameters
for that as well and then finally it's
the same as before this classifier layer
is just KC and HC so down here I would
use this one and the final calculation
that I got if I was doing the final
state then feed that through a
classifier makes sense and you do this
so I do it for a and for B and when I
get to see I create this classifier and
since it's dependent on KC which is
dependent on KB and B which is dependent
on ka and a I've also got lots of info
influences from all these attention
weights that I kept word by word through
the entire processing of the hypothesis
so if you squint I think it makes good
on the intuitions that both of you had
yeah
the intuition behind attention so it
seems like sort of the underlying
hypothesis is that if your
representation state have similar values
right so their dot product or their
matrix multiplication will be similar
but in this case right maybe it's really
useful if you're trying to say that one
thing is not related to the other than
your hypothesis it's not related to your
premise
maybe the states will have very
different values and your attention
would almost make you not pay attention
to that at all
like I guess at what point does it make
sense that you're always assuming that
similar values for your features is what
you want to pay attention to I think
this is a fairly only of the dot product
one right where I've kind of hard-coded
the ideal because I tried to highlight
them in orange here I have three chances
to learn parameters and those parameters
could reflect all of these different
associations so not only strong things
but also weak things right the U and you
see this in visualizations of the
learned weights that you kind of learn
to amplify important pairings and
de-emphasize ones that are not
informative for the final task so this
is kind of like again the data are
speaking very loudly in this case in a
way that they weren't for the dot
product view yeah and let me just
mention a few other variants I mean what
I've done there with those two views I
mean I just picked two that seemed kind
of representative of strategies people
use my personal opinion is that the
literature on attention is kind of hard
to read because there are so many
variants and when you open up a new
paper and see that people have tried a
different view of attention it's hard to
know where the meaningful differences
are and where they're just kind of
incidental implementation details but I
hope you're now armed to think like
there's kind of these two classes global
with like a pretty hard-coded values
about what attention weights should be
like on up to this one which is like
very freely learning word by word what
the attention weight should be other
variants so long it also applied export
exploit local attention which is like
instead of looking at the entire premise
when forming whatever vector of
attention weights I'm going to a form I
look only at a controlled window
I think that's most applicable in
situations like machine translation
where you have lots of output states and
so you're kind of moving through the
hypothesis attending to different local
windows in the premise or I should say
the source and target languages for
machine translation or for like language
modeling or dialogue which could have a
lot of output States for nli it kind of
seems like it's that final state that
really matters and then you might as
well attend to the entire premise yeah
that works
yeah I sort of mentioned that down here
and we're gonna talk about those later
this is what I mean by um attention has
become kind of kind of pervasive and
maybe even the primary source of
connection let me just go through these
now before getting to that so word by
word attention this thing that I showed
you here can be set up in many ways and
you could have many more learned
parameters and as an extreme case of
that this ROC techel paper which was
really foundational and showing that
attention is powerful for nli they
basically seem to have taken the view
that for every one of the matrices that
you have here you have associated
embedding weights or transformation
weights so they have a lot more double
use that would be in Orange
if you depicted their full model but I
think that with this summary here it's
kind of the same intuition which is as
you troop through the hypothesis infuse
every state that you look at with an
attention weighted version of the entire
premise and learn parameters along the
way you could attend you could um as you
troop through the hypothesis upend
attention weights from the premise at
each time step
that's another variant that Luong at all
explore and then relevant to things like
the transformer so a recent development
which I think we'll talk about in a
couple of weeks is that in the usual
framing like the one I've taken for this
lecture
the primary connections are the RNN ones
and then you do this like additional
layer of attention connections and in
the paper I think this is the one that's
called attention is all you need the
idea there is that drop the basic
recurrent network connections and just
have lots of attention
mechanisms and in my view what that's
doing is kind of just saying for every
point that I'm at in an example just
freely explore connections to my
neighborhood maybe through that
throughout the whole example and just
see if there are any influences anywhere
around me that are relevant for solving
my problems so it's a very open-ended
way of exploring the data it doesn't
even encode kind of the linear structure
that you get from an RNN but those those
are proven to be really powerful and
then as a final kind of more indirect
connection but still interesting the
memory networks that were developed a
few years ago they're kind of similar to
attention mechanisms in the sense that
they're trying with additional augmented
representations to address the fact that
your network might be sort of forgetting
things as it processes examples but the
mechanism there is quite different so
here you have this kind of memory store
representation as opposed to additional
attention connections but of course
those ideas could be combined as well
okay that's very technical stuff but I
hope you feel if you weren't already
kind of prepared to dive into the
literature it will be rewarding I think
it's a very clear result at this point
that for lots of problems in NLU
attention mechanisms are valuable
excellent so final phase here I wanted
to show you some error analyses and some
suggest some new possibilities for doing
this so I mentioned the multi nli
annotations here I've given a few
examples the annotations are on the left
I think there are 16 categories for them
and all they're doing is just giving you
know a human's judgment about certain
important semantic properties of the
examples so this one is modal and Co ref
because it has kin in here and it sort
of got an anaphora connection between
students of human misery and those who
study human misery negation tense
difference conditional quantifier active
passive this active passive thing is
nice they consolidated programs to
increase efficiency and programs to
increase efficiency
consolidated you know like it's not
surprising that that's a common strategy
for people who are constructing examples
and it's really interesting to ask of
your system whether head it has learned
the kind of human linguistic thing that
active passive variants preserve some
aspects of meaning or many aspects of
meaning so just as a kind of example of
something you might do I used some of my
own Amazon credits that I got along with
you all to just run a bunch of
experiments on the cloud just using the
course code so I did logistic regression
with cross product features and I
explored like the regularization
strength and the penalty type l1 l2 and
then for L STM's I did a chained one so
that's the most naive version where you
have shared parameters across premise
and hypothesis as well as a sentence
encoding one which I just pulled out of
that notebook that I showed you and I
explored the embedding dimension the
hidden dimensionality and the learning
rate and the activation function up here
I've given the performance on the
thousand or so annotated examples so the
logistic regression was best chained and
then sentence encoding just as an aside
here I noted I wanted to store all the
model parameters so that I could test
them on new cases the model file for the
logistic regression is over 600
megabytes because it has 16 million
features the cross-product feature space
is really large contrast that with the
LST ends where the model files are each
about a megabyte so you know this
performance difference if I wanted to
run these models on a phone then I just
can't use the logistic regression right
but these these models down here are
nice and compact an important thing to
keep in mind Oh for the annotations I
don't know that's a good question I
should have checked it be quick to check
though because those models are quick to
train I'm less concerned though with the
absolute performance although it would
be nice to bring it into the mix for an
error analysis but what I was really
interested in is just that you have this
view
absolute performance where maybe
logistic regression is best but how are
they different to these different
annotation categories so there are like
16 of them so I group them in a few ways
these are the categories where all the
models are more often correct than
incorrect that's a kind of high level
summary and that's active-passive
antonyms belief reports conditionals
long sentences modal's and negation it's
pretty good ok and it's good that there
are a lot of them where they're doing
they're more often correct and incorrect
here's the one case where all the models
were more incorrect and correct so this
is presumably no matter what your model
the hardest and this is quantity time
reasoning and this doesn't surprise me
because I think a lot of the models and
also the feature spaces are just not
sensitive to this low-level kind of
stuff it's very subtle this is a classic
case of a very small set of semantic
morphemes having very large consequences
for what the overall sentences mean and
so I'm not surprised that this is a hard
one here's a case where only the
logistic regression was more often
correct and incorrect the other models
were the reverse and that's ko ref
intense differences that's kind of
interesting the tense difference one
makes sense to me in the sense that the
word product model first of all is
keeping track of all of these pairs but
since I didn't do any stemming or other
normalization it also knows about
differences in tents and so it has this
enormous space of features and it's just
kind of pretty well attuned to the fact
that you might have like was to is
because it has that directly represented
whereas the LST M's are probably
struggling because they probably end up
with pretty similar representations for
the tense variance because they occur in
a lot of the same environments and you
might tell a similar story for the ko
ref case here's one where only the chain
del s TM was more correct than incorrect
and this is word overlap that's kind of
surprising to me I don't have an
explanation for that
this would make perfect sense if I had
added some attention mechanisms but I
didn't and I would have thought that the
logistic regression would be really good
at this but it's just about you know
50/50
and here the finally here the cases
where only the sentence encoding Alice
team was more incorrect and correct so
the other two models were better right
this is our worst model remember and
this is paraphrasing quantifier I don't
have a deep explanation for this I guess
except that it's the worst worst of the
three yeah I swear the initial input
embeddings weren't random instead or
something I considered it but I took the
philosophical view that I would
introduce no outside information in this
competition and since the logistic
regression model can't benefit from
glove vectors at least not in the way
that I implemented it I would also not
give the other models that advantage my
hunch is that if I brought in rich
initialization then the Ellis tans would
just jump up in performance but they'd
have a lot more information at their
disposal products such a large feature
space yeah like I gave these three
players the data but another dimension
to this problem would be if I compared
an LST m with and without Burt
representations for its words where do
the differences arise and I think this
could again illuminate like you probably
even have some expectations that it's
going to do better at things like that
involve general lexical information
maybe word overlap antonyms maybe belief
negation but long sentence might be
unaffected by this outside information
maybe not though couple more things so
another thing that you can do in nli is
resort to some linguistic expectations
that you might have so you could ask for
example does your model know that
negation is downward monotone that is
can it get right consistently that Fido
ran entails Fido moved and Fido didn't
remove entails Fido didn't run so the up
arrow means I have entailment in that
direction
down entailment in that direction and
what this would mean for your model of
course is that any example that you
plugged in may be where you would say
where it got this right if I do just add
a negation it should get this one right
in my experience these models disappoint
you that they have not learned this and
you will certainly be disappointed if
you try something a little bit more
sophisticated like does your model know
that every is downward monotone on its
first argument and upward on its second
this is a semantic fact that I think is
very clear but your model probably will
not have the systematicity that leads
you to think that yes it has fully
encoded this logical fact you will find
some examples where it seems to be
behaving in accord with this
generalization and others where it does
something quite crazy even if it is
performing well on a large scale
assessment like SN Li and that's
something to think about here's a
related thing just by way of wrapping up
so I've mentioned before that that bill
as part of his thesis did lots of rich
work on natural logic applying it to nli
tasks and natural that logic has the
characteristic that it has very
sophisticated little algebras of
semantic relationships and I've
summarized one here this is a kind of
theory of negation where you know if I
have P and Q are disjoint like dog and
couch then the negation of those two are
neutral and I filled out this whole
table here and you can construct
artificial data sets where you just
insist that the lexical items so to
speak have certain semantic
relationships like entailment
consistency overlap contradiction and
then you can define the algebra on top
of them and construct as many examples
as you want in a kind of algorithmic
fashion in past years of this class
we've done this as a homework problem
just to have people confront these
semantic subtleties and so then you
could ask if you train your model on a
doubly negated data set an artificial
one that you create like you know naught
naught P naught naught Q does it
generalize to the Triple E negated cases
you might think it should right it
should have all the information that you
need at that point because it's seen the
base cases it's seen single negation and
it should now know that double negation
just kind of flips you back or you know
flips you to another systemic space in
this little algebra but again I think
it's unlikely that your model has fully
learned this algebra and you will see
that as you try to ask it to make
predictions about longer and longer
sequences and this is a nice way to
stress test your model and I've given a
few examples of papers that I think do
this quite well including one by yes
who's on the teaching team yeah that's a
good point like the unneeded cases the
singly and the doubly I would think that
that's giving your model a fair chance
to have seen all the relevant kinds of
patterns and it should have everything
it needs now to generalize to and so
forth for example language for this
probing artificial data case this is
meant to be separate separate from any
intuitions you might have about negation
this is more like testing the sense in
which the model is doing something
systematic in the sense of cognitive
science like has it really learned to
abstract from your data a kind of
systematic pattern as embodied in this
little algebra up here and this is just
nice because since you control all of
the all aspects of the model
and the data that come in you can have a
pretty good sense for whether you've
posed this in a fair way and that could
give you insight into what your model is
actually capable of learning for the
more general and interesting linguistic
question of whether or not parameters
you've learned on one language would
transfer to others there are experiments
of people trying to do that and in fact
you can try that for an li because that
facebook group released a version of
multi nli that is multilingual pursuing
the hypothesis that there might be some
abstract layers of representation that
are good for multiple languages yeah yes
are you ultimately limited to feeding
your models certain things and seeing
what it spits out and you can't sort of
look inside and like look obviously it's
not easy to say have you learned a
concept and like look at the activations
but is this still sort of the main way
of asking this question it's just
throwing things in saying what comes out
I'm just smiling because I sort of feel
like the answer is yes and this is just
an amusing because it's like a sense in
which deep learning has become like a
psychology experiment where instead of
having humans come into the lab where
you probe them behaviorally to see what
they know you now have this black box
model that you probe behaviorally to see
what it knows there are great papers
that are trying to push us past this
where you do kind of you have another
model that does some local expection of
the parameters or maybe looks at how
different examples as they pass through
the network activate different parts of
it to give you insight into what they
actually have encoded but I think a lot
of it still comes down to this kind of
behavioral thing which is not
necessarily bad it just means that you
might also want to get good at running
human subject experiments so that your
artificial agents are treated fairly and
the protocols a sort of related to this
seeing some kind of optimism that
attention is not only kind of a
performance enhancer but maybe also some
kind of explanatory metric that you know
you can look at what is my model
you're paying attention to and maybe get
some insights there but I was just
talking to someone recently he was
saying there's been a paper published
recently saying that attention actually
is not any good for this it doesn't
actually help us explain things
wondering if you have any insight on
that yeah again I think they're
differing opinions my view would be let
me give you two view so first for nli
when you look at the heat maps of the
different attention weights that head
has learned on word by word attention
those seem often to be quite
illuminating to me and do kind of
reflect what you would expect that
certain pairs of words across premise
and hypothesis are really informative
about the classification label so I
think that all looks good to me
conversely like I was really excited
when I saw people adding attention
mechanisms into these problems because
it kind of looked like it was a soft
parse of the example like a dependency
parse and I thought that would be really
cool because maybe you'd be able to read
off of the attention weights what the
true parse was or maybe what the top
most likely parse is for this utterance
were and I think that that dream is not
quite realized it's less clear that
that's happening but for the nli case I
think this is like one ask one way of
making good on what on your what your
goal was do you have different views
we'll talk more about attention when we
talk about the transformer and Burt and
Elmo because attention is a big part of
what makes those models work I think
that was a lot of material and so I
think I won't try in this in these last
few minutes to do the ambitious thing of
showing you too much about these
grounding slides they are up and let me
just show you just one thing so this is
about grounding and what I did is I gave
you a bunch of linguistic insights about
why grounded language understanding is
important and then I framed this as
speakers listeners chatbots
and reasoning about other minds and so
I'll just say that speakers that would
be like what I've done for a lot of
these slides is focusing on colors
people describing colors because it's a
simple version of a very large class of
interesting problems and colors are
great because they have like cognitive
complexity and linguistic complexity so
for speakers here you could think of
models that are learning to describe
colors and there's great data for that
and this is a nice manageable problem
that would allow you to confront like
color to sequence all right so color
comes in and then you need to produce a
description then the listener view is
the converse right so somebody gives you
a color description and you need to make
a guess about what color they're
describing that's interestingly
different the inputs are different and
the output space is a little bit harder
to deal with
then the grounded chatbots you've
probably heard about chatbots I think
that they're often kind of kind of at
sea because they're just using language
and producing language and they're not
like actually connected to any problem
or any social situation this group this
face book paper on negotiation is a data
set where you have chat BOTS that are
grounded in a goal-oriented task and I
think that's very exciting and so I've
just tried to present their model in its
basic form and you should know that it's
a really cool data set and then for
other minds I've sort of made a
connection between pragmatics and
machine learning and another interesting
thing about that is that it
you have a bunch of really interesting
quite manageable datasets for doing
projects on and you guys are really well
prepared to think about all of these
models you'll find if you look through
you'll see that because basically all of
them are like nli models where instead
of having just one label you have a
label for every stage in your hypothesis
or in your output space from what's
called the decoder part of the problem
really easy to implement based on what
you guys have already done and then you
have all these cool datasets to think
about so I'm going to give you much more
detail about that on Monday but if
you're still casting about for projects
you might page through this and just
maybe follow the links to various data
sets and so forth because it is such a
rich space but let's stop for now that's
been enough content thanks everyone